toi oui on va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la pâte est en émoi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai craqué mon potton
saad et moi merci vous avez décidé de
chic puisque vous avez trouvé l'amour
exactement alors sur quoi pour tout
problème c'est que ça fait plusieurs
fois qui trouve l'amour c'est souvent
non mais là c'est un vrai alors elle est
très jolie une fois de plus et jean mi
bravo à eux
voilà annoncé
[Applaudissements]
c'est assez technique au but mais j'ai
passé des vacances assez horrible mais
c'est un tout permettez je voulais dire
pourquoi parce que je voulais voir
[Rires]
pendant les vacances les deux mois on
n'est pas ensemble
et bah ma vie n'est pas non plus
beaucoup de sens j'ai même un autre aveu
à vous faire c'est que début août et
faites vous appeler et pourquoi j'ai pas
fait son deuil peut surfer j'aimerais
faire lui si j'entends votre voix je
vais peut-être me mettre à chialer comme
à gauche les menteurs voilà là c'est un
autre délire pas du bon pied
non mais franchement c'est important
parce que normalement
toi tu me mesure combien 1 m 75 tu poses
du combien syndicats 30-40 ça va parce
que tu as pas d y est douce tu vois pas
ce que normalement je connais cette
année neuf normalement de cette taille
là ils ont des péniches quoi sans
déconner quand on a pris notre ouïe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais non ils ne sont pas là les gens
là tout un débrief sur l émission
famille c'est votre chat machine qu'est
ce que tu as fait penser va construire
garde un petit peu ce que tu as fait à
roubaix lesquels vont alors tout est
beau vous mettez les chaussures trop
petites
[Rires]
en principe faut se mettre dans le sens
du service vous commença alors cet été
on avait plus de chance de le voir sur
teen d'heures que à la télévision je
reconnais que je reconnais que j'étais
un petit peu coquin ah ouais alors
emparé sans trahir un secret mais vous
avez 28 conquête soir à wil hahn suite
ouais ok tu sais si c'est ce qu'on
m'avait dit si abdou tu le dis comme ça
le colosse tu te jettes ça comme ça
enfin sûr c'est que le chiffre médian du
[Applaudissements]
28 conquête rendez compte on pas
gratuite
il ne faut pas me donner un petit surnom
cédéthèque été très chaud pour le cinéma
la [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]